[拍手]
英語が
話せないこと
あれ
おっ何でしょうか
いやふざけんなよおい
あーよかったですよかったです
緊張してるんすよなんだ世界チャンピオン
のあとなんでねありがとうございます
びっくりさえちょっとごめんなさいはい僕
は英語で英語を話せませんと
言わせていただきましたかっこいいですよ
ね英語って英語話せないんでちょっと言っ
てみたかったんですまあ10秒だけ
ここから日本語で話します皆さん
リラックスできましたかね
僕には
生活をする上で感じるいくつかの
障害があります
そのうちの1つか
身長が
191cmあることなんです
僕は
三重県長島スパーランドの
看板アトラクションである
スチールドラゴンあれに乗ることができ
ません
なんでかというとそう
身長が高すぎるからなんです
皆さんは
全国の遊園地や
テーマパークにある多くの乗り物に
身長制限が設けられてのご存知でしょうか
しかも
上の
僕はまあいわゆる絶叫系と
言われる乗り物
乗るのが大好きなんで
昼ドラゴンに乗れないっていうのはかなり
僕にとっては辛いんです
それなのに
友達と
長島に行くと
深夜だっけスチールドラマ乗られへんの
おもろ
俺らだけ乗ってくるか
待っといてくれや
そう僕に言うんです
ああいうとき
僕はこんなに身長があることに
落ち込むんですよね
なんで
スチールドラゴンのサイズもっと大きく
ないんやろうって
僕だけが思ってると思います
他にも障害はありますそれはお酒にとって
も弱いことなんです
運動部に所属していた頃よく大会の
打ち上げとして
居酒屋で
飲み会が開催されていました
そこではお疲れ様
お酒で乾杯一口2口飲んだまあ30分後
ぐらいですかね
僕は自分の意志に反して
眠ってしまうんです
まあでもだいたいしばらくするとまた目が
覚めるのでまたみんなの真ん中に入って
乾杯
ぐっと飲んだらやっぱりこうなってしまう
んですよね
これ寝てますからねはいそうなんですこう
なってしまうんですでしまいには
キャプテンが僕のとこに来て
おいしいんや深夜
帰る時間や
会計一人5000円5000円
僕一口2口しか飲んでないっすよ
えっ
僕打ち上げ楽しんでましたかいや知らんが
お前が勝って寝取ったやんけこういう
やり取りは僕の中では日常茶飯事なんです
よね
お酒の席になると
僕のこのお酒が飲めないっていう
体質を
本当に悔しく思います
てかそもそも
ファミレス打ち上げやってくれよって
本気でそう思ってます
さて
僕はこれら自分自身の特徴を
障害というふうに
捉えましたまあ実際にそれぞれの状況に
応じて
僕が自分自身の困難を乗り越えられてい
ないんだからまあ障害というふうに言え
ますよねでも
僕は障害を持っているから障害者なんです
よ
かっていうと多くの人は否定すること
でしょうではなんで
僕は障害者ではないのでしょうか
ここで一つ
考えることがあるんじゃないかなと思って
ますそれは
障害ってどういう意味ということです
障害という言葉だけを聞くと
まあ人によって捉え方や解釈が若干違うん
じゃないかなと思いますなのでこのトーク
を
進めるにあたって僕も1つ
障害を定義したいと思います
僕の定義する障害とは
環境や状況によって見え隠れするものです
少し難しい言葉で言い換えると
環境や状況によって
潜在したり
顕在したりするものです
この後
洗剤と建材という言葉を多用しますので
少し説明を加えておきますね
洗剤とは
ポテンシャル
うちに秘めて
外からは見えないといったような状態を
指します反対に
顕在とは
意識下にある
表面に現れている
外からの3つからもはっきりと見えるそう
いったような状態を指します
障害の潜在健在をイメージしてもらいたい
ので
皆さん
この
トークの冒頭で話した
英語のセンテンスを思い出してください
はい皆さんが失笑してたやつですね
あの瞬間皆さん中では
原田英語で喋るの最悪
私
英語できないのに
トーク聞けないじゃん
その他方いらっしゃいませんか
いやいますよねはい僕も英語できないんで
そう思います
そう思ったあなたあの瞬間あの瞬間だけは
あなたの
潜在していた
英語力に関する
障害が不と
顕在してきた瞬間と言えるのではない
でしょうか
じゃあ次に
僕についても考えてみましょう
皆さん僕は見てください
皆さん僕見て今どう思ってますか
なんとも思わねえよ
カッコつけてんじゃねーよなんでそのT
シャツ
ちゃんとズボン履けよ
そういう風に思いましたかいいんですどう
思っていただいてもでも
僕はこうやってトークをするにあたって
いやいや
身長英語力お酒への対お酒への体質が
障害になっとるよって思った方いますかね
多分いないんじゃないでしょうか
でももしここの天井が190センチしか
なかったら
もしここが日本ではなくて
テッドの本部であるアメリカだったら
もし
僕らの控え室にある飲み物がすべてお酒
だったら
そのような環境下だと
僕の
身長
英語力お酒の体質は今こうやってトークを
する上で大きく
顕在した障害となっていたことでしょう
今
僕がこうやって皆さんの前でトークをして
いられるのは
この
環境が
僕の持つ障害を
潜在させてくれているからに
過ぎないんです
どうですか
僕が考える
障害の定義は伝わりましたかね
障害とは
環境や状況によって
潜在したり
顕在したりするこの考えを指示しますと
皆さんにも
多くの潜在した障害を持っていることに
なります
例えば
もしこのように
メガネやコンタクトは存在しなかったら
あなたの
視力が低いという
潜在的な障害は今この瞬間でさえも
顕在していたことでしょう
もし
医療保険
制度は整備されておらず今の医療負担の
割合が3割ではなく10割だったら
あなたがお金持ちではないという
潜在的な障害は小さな毛が
病気をした時にでさえ
治療費を払うときに大きく
健在していたことでしょう
もし
多様性や個性が尊重されず
淘汰されてしまう集団に所属していたら
あなたの一風変わった趣味思考を持って
いるという
潜在的な障害はそれらを
他人に披露したり
共有したりする時にでさえ
顕在していたことでしょう
今一度
普段は
潜在しているけども
特定の環境状況になると
顕在するあなたの
障害について
考えてみてほしいんです
さああなたはいくつ思いつきますか
唐突ではありますが
ここで僕の好きな言葉を紹介しますそれは
リハビリテーションです
皆さんも
言葉自体は聞いたことあるでしょうでも
この言葉
少し
誤解されて広まってるんですね
よく
リハビリハビリと
言われるリハビリテーションですが日本で
は
全人間的復旧と訳され何らかの障害が原因
で
安全な社会生活を送れなくなってしまった
人々を対象に
再び
安全な社会生活を
送れるようにするまでの過程のすべてを
意味します
ここでいう障害とは
歩けない
耳が聞こえないと言ったようなものだけで
はなくて
先ほど
僕が例示してきたようなものをはじめ
あらゆる種類のものが
当てはまるんです
特に
普段の
社会生活で
顕在した
障害を持っている人々の多くは今この瞬間
も
リハビリテーション
取り組んでいる途中かもしれません
それは
医学的な障害を持っているというだけでは
なくて
性的マイノリティである
ホームレスである
前科前歴がある
特定の人種民族である
技能実習生などの
外国人労働者であるなどとカテゴライズさ
れる人々もまた
リハビリテーションの
途中かもしれません
自分自身の障害に向き合いその人が望む
その人らしい生活を
獲得するまでの
過程そのものが
リハビリテーションとっても
美しい概念だと思いませんか
しかしその彼らの
リハビリテーションも
慢性的に阻害しているものがあるんです
しかもそれはあなたも大きく関わっている
かもしれないのですそれが
障害者に対する
偏見です
世の中には
障害者や社会的弱者と
ラベリングされてしまっている人に対して
偏見を抱いたり
差別的現動したりする人は見受けられます
まあ僕も皆さんも人間ですのである
対象に対して
偏った見方をしてしまうこと自体はある
程度は
仕方がないとは思うんです
ですが
負の感情を伴った偏見を
個人の中だけではなく
外部に表明することでしかもそういう人が
自分だけではなくたくさん存在することで
元々
心の中だけであったはずの偏見が
人々の間で共有されてしまうやがて
社会が持つ
障害者に対する偏見へと
変容してしまうんです
彼らに対して
偏見を抱いたりしゃべって言動したりする
ことは社会で共有されているようでは
いくら
彼らの
物理的
経済的
制度的な環境が完璧に
整っていたとしても
彼らの心理的
安全が保障されない限り
リハビリテーションの
満足いく実現というのはなされません
でもこういう話をするといやいやいやいや
それ本人が頑張ってへんだけやろって
まあそういう人が一定数います
その意見でも少し待ってください
本来
社会の偏見というのは
莫大な
力を秘めてるんです
それに
個人が一人で立ち向かおうだなんてそう
簡単な話ではありません
ネットでの誹謗中傷が
想像しやすい身近な例かと思いますがあの
ように
社会の負のベクトルが
個人に向かうことで僕ら1人の人間の心
なんて簡単に
壊されてしまうんですこれこそこれこそが
リハビリテーションを阻害する最大の
インチだと
僕は思うんですよねだから
安易に他人があいつは頑張ってないだけと
か言ってその問題を自分の中で勝手に
片付けるのは
違うんじゃないかなってそう思うんですよ
ね
逆の立場になっても考えてみてください
僕はこのトークを通じて
誰にでも
潜在している障害はありその障害は特定の
環境状況下で
必ず
顕在するとそう言い続けてきました
つまりその特定の環境状況下になったら
あなたも
社会の偏見の対象になるかもしれないん
です
自分がそうなったとき
同じことが言いますか
いやいやいや
社会の偏見ぐらい
余裕で跳ね返せるし
そう大きな声で言えますか
僕にはそんな軽々しく言えません
皆さんもそうではないでしょうか
だから今日この瞬間から
皆さんにも
障害を持つ
当事者としてこの問題について向き合って
いただきたいんです
では
どのようにこの社会問題について向き合え
ばいいのか
僕が考えるに
目の前の人の人となりを
捉えるよう努めてみてください
それが大切だと思ってるんです
言い換えると
目の前の人を
顕在した
障害の有無や
程度や
種類で
判断するのではなく
僕らが身につけている
偏見というレンズの入ったメガネを
外してから
人と接してみるようにしてほしいんです
それが僕ら一人一人にできることだと思う
んですよね
確かにさっきも言いました
偏見は
持ってしまうこと自体は仕方がない
こんなことを言ってる僕がやってね
昔は
髪の毛染めとる人
みんなチャラいんでしょと
パソコンとか
ゲームめっちゃできても
運動できんのでしょ
偏見持ってましたよ何
個も何個
メガネかけてましたよ
でもみんながみんなそうじゃないじゃない
ですか
当てはまってる人いるかもしれませんでも
100%そんな
わけないじゃないですか
このように
僕らの持っている偏見というのは
事実や本質と
異なることも多いんです
だからこそ
事実や本質を捉えていない恐れのある
偏見というレンズの
入ったメガネをかけたまま
目の前の人を判断するのではなくこの
メガネを外して
目の前の人と
接してみてほしいんです
皆さん一人一人がそのように努めて
くださることで
個人の持つ偏見だけではなく
社会で共有される偏見をも小さくし
すべての人が笑顔になりすべての人が最高
の
リハビリテーションをいつでも
実現を目指せる社会になることでしょう
最後に改めて
僕が皆さんに伝えたいことを強調します
障害はみんな持っておりその障害は
環境や状況によって
潜在したり顕在したりする
偏見や差別は
誰かの
リハビリテーションの最大の蘇我因子と
なっている
目の前の人を
顕在した
障害で判断するのではなくその人の
人となりを捉えよう
皆さんもこの3つの考え方アイデアを
持ち帰っていただいてどんな
障害があろうとも
すべての人が
笑顔になるような
社会の実現を
共に
目指していきましょう
そして
[音楽]
あー嬉しいですありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
スタンディングオベーションまでね
ありがとうございますはいありがとう
ございますいや皆さんいい笑顔ですねはい
どんな障害を持つ人と
接する時もその笑顔で今度こそ
ご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]